but first the gop's
great reset that's the focus of
tonight's angle
now weeks ago the angle warned pelosi
and company that
impeachment would only help trump but
they listen to the crazies instead
now the second impeachment fiasco was a
total disaster for the democrats
trump was acquitted exactly zero minds
were changed
and nothing was accomplished except
donald trump
emerged stronger and the congress weaker
now a recent poll conducted by the
liberal leaning website vox
made two important findings one that 69
percent of republican voters
are less likely to back a candidate who
voted to convict trump
and number two 70 of likely gop
voters say they want to see trump run
again in 2024.
now the democrats are going to have to
try to govern at this point right with
impeachment behind them
which they've proven themselves to be
supremely bad at doing
now after all if they could govern
americans wouldn't be
fleeing places like new york and
california
the democrats have relied on both
trump's presence
and virus panic as shields to cover
their
ongoing destruction to our economy our
borders and our foreign policy
but after only one month in office can
you believe it's only been a month
the veil or face mask is off and more
americans are seeing
exactly who the democrats are
and what they intend to do to america
now this development
presents a clear opening for the gop
ten years after the tea party movement
reared up against the democrats and the
old gop
establishment a populist america first
movement
is now the undeniable core of the
republican party
so no matter how often jeff flake or the
sleazy lincoln project grifters appear
on msnbc
we ain't never going back to the bush
cheney style of republicanism
no more support for open borders no more
blank checks for endless wars
no more putting china and multinational
corporations first
never again that version of the gop
is finished with much of the old
establishment on the sidelines though
the gop is
free now to represent its voters that's
a new concept
that means aggressively advancing a
pro-growth
anti-lockdown agenda that puts american
families first
now what's the most important issue
right now that will help our country
and grow our movement we've talked about
this i think all of us together for what
now
10 months opening schools
the democrats stance on reopening
schools is anti-science
and it's just plain evil at this point
it once and all
and for all proves that liberals don't
give a rip about children
who don't have the opportunity to attend
private academies
no they don't and if you ever doubted
that democrats are just puppets
of the teachers unions well you didn't
trust this show you should have
but now you know the ugly truth
my team will work to see that a majority
of our schools can be open
by the end of my first 100 days
that's right his goal that he set is to
have the majority of schools so more
than 50 percent
open by day 100 of his presidency
teaching at least one day a week i think
that the schools really do
need more resources and that's the
reason why the national relief
act that we're talking about getting
passed we need that
well that's a complete and utter joke
even jake tapper
who is essentially canonized anthony
fauci he
choked up a tad the moment he realized
that
schools weren't opening anytime soon i
feel a little dispirited
after this conversation because i had
high hopes that schools would be able to
resume
in-person learning because so many
scientists and health officials
including you and dr fauci and others
have been talking about
the science supports opening the schools
as it sounds to me like you're asking
for
100 mass compliance and a number of
measures that we're never going to be
able to achieve
uh and that makes me feel like boy i
don't know if the schools are
ever going to open duh of course they're
not
they're not going to have to go back to
school in person learning
unless the teachers are forced to do so
now they could buy every teacher a full
space suit
and vaccinate them and install hundreds
of billions of dollars
of new hvac systems in schools and fauci
and biden
would just move on to squawking about
another virus mutations coming
do you really think that the gop is
going to lose ground to a party
that wants to keep kids stuck at home
forever
come on man states like michigan
illinois new york and connecticut
tolerate the bleed
of businesses from their already
high-tax pro-shutdown states
and and who in his or her right mind
would condone today's
covides blame-shifting performance from
andrew cuomo is there anything that you
personally apologize for in this whole
process apologize
look i have said repeatedly
we made a mistake in creating the void
when we didn't provide information it
allowed
press people cynics politicians
to fill the void
give that man another emmy for years
republicans have treated california as
if it's a lost cause
new york pretty much the same but look
at what's happening now
you gotta give credit by the way to the
californians who are finally waking up
to gruesome
newsome the effort to recall one of the
nation's worst governors
has gotten the requisite 1.5 million
signatures i think this was the first
show to really discuss
the fact that it could uh very likely
happen
although by the way i bet the democrat
party will
object to those certifications
now meanwhile our policies the america
first policies
they continue to work for the average
american red states like florida
texas south dakota and tennessee
they're thriving they nixed the lockdown
mentality
and understood from the beginning that
the cure
could not be worse than the disease
now it was last may if you could believe
it or not when the
angle pleaded with the democrat
governors to wake up
it's becoming more obvious by the day
that these
power hungry governors and radical
mayors
are endangering their state's futures
and will eventually
see their states left behind this has
been the pattern
of blue state governors and radical
mayors during covet 19.
they simply don't trust their own
citizens and at times
they seem to relish punishing them
but they wouldn't listen and they're not
going to listen
because at some point along the way this
whole effort
stopped becoming about controlling the
virus and started becoming about
controlling the people
our choices our travel our education
our churches our free speech
anyone who questioned the vaunted
medical establishment
was branded as anti-science a heretic
and also called dangerous when the
history of this pandemic is finally
written
many of the heroes and geniuses of today
will be seen as villains or incompetents
like the democrat and republican
politicians
who saw trump as a bigger threat than
the ccp
and eventually conservative leaders like
ron desantis christie gnome
greg abbott and of course donald trump
will be seen as visionaries for doing
everything in their power
to not only keep americans safe from a
virus
but most importantly keep them free
after a few more years of lockdowns and
racial grievance
government controls and dying state
economies
the america first message will
increasingly resonate with women
young americans new americans latino
americans and yes african americans
and when that happens we're going to be
unstoppable
and that's the angle